The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Why don't we go ahead and
get this started here?
We have a cornucopia of
different silicon materials
out in front here in
display, and we'll
walk through some
of them shortly.
What I wanted to do right
at the beginning of class
was to give a little bit of
an update on quiz number two.
Some of you have probably
seen this already
and are aware that
on Thursday we're
expecting a short
little decision
tree as to how to process your
solar cell to obtain the lowest
dollars per watt peak.
So this little exercise-- it
will last for about a month--
is coincident with
our technology
section of the class.
So remember, we went
through the fundamentals.
Now we're on the technologies.
And then finally, in the
cross-cutting themes.
So coincident with the
technologies portion
is designing your own
solar cell and optimizing
the dollars per watt.
So this will entail actually
fabricating a solar cell, which
is kind of fun.
And Joe will be your guide
throughout this process,
so you'll be able to actually
take a piece of bare silicon
and finish up with a device,
a rudimentary device,
but something to take a picture
yourself, post on Facebook,
that sort of thing.
You design your own solar cell.
So the idea isn't
only to optimize
for the performance
of the solar cell,
but we decided to throw
in a little curve ball
and design for
dollars per watt peak.
Now this is a little bit
of a contrived exercise
since we've arbitrarily chosen
what dollars are associated
with each different
process step,
but it's not too unlike what you
would face in actual industry
if you had real data coming
off a production line
and knew exactly what it
cost for each process step.
So instead of having 30 plus
components in a more detailed
cost model, we've
decided to simplify it
to this little
diagram right here.
So this is a flow chart
for the fabrication
process of your solar cell.
You'll start with a wafer.
It has a certain cost
associated with it.
You'll have some
decisions to make
concerning light
management, whether you
want to texture
your front surface
or whether you want to
leave it bare and reflective
like this right here.
So whether you want a
reflective front service
or you want to
texture it, there's
a certain costs
associated with it.
So you can probably go to some
online resource, like PVCDROM,
and use their simulator or the
one you've already constructed
for homework number
two, and calculate
what the predicted efficiency
boost should be if you
texture your front surface.
Keep in mind on this very
simple solar cell here,
we have no
anti-reflection coating.
So the texturization
is pretty much
all you've got for
light management.
Next, on the emitter,
the choice is
whether to make a deep
emitter or a shallow emitter.
The text goes into
that in some detail.
But your decision is basically
if you make a shallow emitter,
you have less
Auger recombination
in that front region.
And so your blue response to
the device will be better.
But you run the risk when you
do your contact metalization
of firing through that
very shallow emitter
and shunting your device.
Whereas, if you decide
to go for a deep emitter,
it stays longer inside
of the furnace because
of the phosphorus will diffuse
deeper inside of the device.
You blue response
will be poorer,
but you'll have less
risk of shunting.
So it's up to you to
use all of the tools
that you've assembled so far
to make a value-based judgment
whether or not it makes
sense to go with this or that
as your selection choice.
And finally, narrow
and wide fingers,
this you can probably
guess already
pertains to series resistance
and shading losses.
So these are all
representative of trade-offs,
trade-offs in terms
of the technology
and trade-offs in terms of cost.
And you have all the tools
necessary to calculate
or estimate what these
outputs should be based
on what you've learned so far.
And so by Thursday,
what we've asked
you to do is to make an
estimate of what technology
pathway your company
is going to pursue.
Remember, you want to
optimize the dollars per watt.
You want to minimize
that quantity, which
means you want to reduce
the number of dollars
you invest in your solar cell.
But you also want to
increase the watt peak
that you get out of it.
And so at the end
of the day, it'll
be a performance/cost
trade-off in each
of these different
process steps right here.
And sometimes it won't
be entirely obvious
which one to choose because
so many factors will converge.
And so it'll be up to you
to make an engineering
decision, a professional
judgment, as to which path
you should pursue.
Since it is kind of--
you know, there's
a little element of
competition in here,
so we decided the
dollars per watt peak
shouldn't be completely
neglected at the end
and we all get
certificates of merit
and all feel good
about ourselves.
We decided it should be worth
some part of the grade, but not
such a large
portion of the grade
that everybody's freaking
out and saying, oh my gosh,
I don't have the right
tools to make this decision.
I feel like I'm not
being graded fairly.
So the portion of
dollars per watt
is really only going
to be affecting
10% of the final grade
of quiz number two.
And so it will be based
on a ranking system where
the highest one will
be 100% and so forth.
But just 10% of your grade.
So it's enough to,
I would say, create
maybe a sting of the
pride if you don't happen
to hit the highest
performance metric, but not
enough to sting the actual
final grade of your class, which
will be one lumped quiz,
quiz one, home works, final,
and so forth.
Right?
Any questions about
quiz two so far?
Yes, Jessica?
AUDIENCE: I
completely understand,
but there's even a
note in number three
under the deep emitter.
And you guys say,
any numbers you
should give as
far as [INAUDIBLE]
or are they responsible
for [INAUDIBLE].
It seems like its
lacking some numbers.
And I understand
optimization, but I'm
having trouble putting
just how much better.
And it say it'll be much more
effective if you do etching.
Well, how much is
much more effective?
PROFESSOR: Oh, the
etching for the--
AUDIENCE: For the etching,
we gave a rough [INAUDIBLE].
So you can look that up.
AUDIENCE: I did look that up.
And for the other ones, is there
AUDIENCE: So that one, you can
get a pretty good estimate for.
AUDIENCE: OK.
For the other ones, is there
going to be a [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: In terms of
shunting your device,
it's really hard to predict
the shock resistance.
But if you do shunt your
device, you essentially ruin it.
So I would just take
that into account.
You're not going to
get exact answers.
But you can do your best
to estimate [INAUDIBLE]
resistance from the [INAUDIBLE]
spacing and your emitter
thinness.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Believe it or not,
you might feel
like you don't have
the tools right now
to get quantitative
answers, but you do.
You have a number
of the tools here
to get, say, 90% the way there.
And in engineering,
90% of the way
there is well beyond what you'll
actually face in the field.
So that's pretty good.
If you have specific
questions about what
would be a good
resource to look up
about this, what would be a good
resource to look up about that,
send an email.
And what I'll do, if I receive
something in that nature,
I'll respond to the
class so that everybody
has benefit to that
information and no one person
is particularly advantaged.
So it's worth a try.
If it's something that was just
covered yesterday in lecture,
I might be a little
bit more reticent.
But if it is something
to the effect of,
gee, how would the
lifetime improve
with these different gettering
scenarios, sure, absolutely.
We can give you a
little hand there.
But everything else,
you should definitely
have that information
available so far.
This is meant to be a fun
exercise, but also one
that illustrates the
trade-offs involved
with designing solar cells.
And trade-offs very
similar to this
are evaluated on a
daily basis in industry,
or perhaps not quite as often
as they should be in industry.
But at some point, they were.
And the designer of
the manufacturing line
made those judgment calls.
OK.
So again, the pre-analysis,
what is due on Thursday
is 20% of the grade.
The dollars per watt peak
metric, at the end of the day,
is only 10% of the grade.
It's meant to really serve
as a stimulus, a little bit
of competition, but not
meant to really harm you
if you happen to not
achieve a good value there.
And this is meant to be
an educational mission,
so the solar cell efficiency
analysis at the end
is really heavily weighted.
We'll be walking through
some of the characterization
tools in the
laboratory so you can
determine what exactly went
wrong with your devices
and quantify them.
And that'll be a
real chance for you
to get a tutorial of how
solar cells are not only
made-- you'll be there when
they're actually fabricated--
but also how they're analyzed
and how they're assessed.
So it's up to you to really
grab this opportunity.
Maybe if you're working
in your own devices
and want to bring
some of them along,
you're welcome to
do that as well.
We won't take up the time when
everyone else is in the room,
but we might stay
longer afterward
and help you walk through
the analysis as well.
And what we've done, just
to resituate ourselves,
we talked about the
silicon feedstock, right?
So we chatted about
how you go from quartz
in the ground and the
carbon-baring feedstock
material to the purified, highly
purified, silicon feedstock
material.
This right here is
probably on the order
of somewhere between
8, 9, or 10 nines pure,
very, very pure material,
this Siemens-grade polysilicon
right here in my hand.
And you've taken a look
at this during last class,
so you have a sense of what
it is up close and personal.
Silicon, in fact, has
been so well refined
that, for a period of
time, NIST, the National
Institutes of Standards
in Technologies,
they were thinking about
redefining the unit of mass
in terms of a silicon
boule, essentially a silicon
sphere, that would be polished
down to about 4 nanometers
mean surface roughness
with a very low defect
density, isotopically
pure silicon
to serve as a new
standard for mass
because it could just
be purified so well
and because their standard
reference units were beginning
to shift relative
to all the others
around the world,
the one in Paris
relative to the ones that were
stored in Washington and Delhi
and others around the world.
The values of the mass were
shifting as a function of time
when they would perform
these round-robin.
So either the mass
in Paris was changing
or everybody else was changing.
This obviously was
unacceptable for an institute
that was focused on standards.
And so they decided
to reformulate
the standard for mass.
I'm not quite sure where that
project currently stands.
So if anybody has
further information
about the NIST unit of mass,
I'd be happy to hear it.
But that gives you an idea of
how well-purified silicon can
be and how well-controlled
it can be as well.
During the integrated
circuit fabrication,
which uses this ultra
purity silicon to produce
very nice single crystal wafers
like this one right here,
the investment per gram of
silicon can be on the order
a few tens or even low hundreds
of dollars per gram of silicon
and still turn a profit.
But in the solar cell,
on the other hand,
you can invest, at
most, a few tens
of cents per gram of silicon.
This is because
the solar cell has
to compete against bulk power.
That's its
competition coming out
of the wall right over there.
So the solar cell has to be
able to be produced much more
cheaply.
And as a result,
typically thinner wafers
are used and less expensive
starting materials and faster
growth methods, resulting in
more defect-rich materials.
So one group decided, gee,
the embedded cost in the wafer
is just so large,
it's just so large
that we have to make it thinner.
And we have to avoid using these
ingots, like this one right
here, from which
these wafers are sawn.
So your wafers are sawn
out of the ingot like this,
like shown.
During the process, about 50% of
the silicon is lost to sawdust.
And they said, well, let's
develop a better way.
Let's extrude the
wafers directly out
of liquid molten silicon
and make ribbons of silicon
instead.
That way, we don't
have the sawdust,
and we don't have to have this
expensive ingot solidification
step.
So ribbon growth
has been explored
since the 1970s at least.
And the advantages is that
you have no kerf loss,
in other words, no sawdust, due
to wire sawing and, hence, more
efficient silicon utilization.
Immediately out of the gate,
if your wafer yields are
comparable, you get
about a factor of 2 gain
because this wafer right here
is about 170 microns thick.
And the sawdust is around
170 microns as well.
So that's about a
factor of 2 if you're
able to produce a
ribbon of silicon
directly out of the melt.
The disadvantage is that
traditionally there's
been lower material
quality and, hence,
lower performance
because of the thermal
stresses during
growth of a very, very
thin foil or thin fin.
The thermal stresses
can be larger,
resulting in plasticity,
resulting in dislocations
and other defects that can
reduce minority carrier
lifetime.
And traditionally, there has
been as well a higher capex.
And a third disadvantage,
traditionally, in ribbon
has been that the form factor
or the shape of the wafer
has just been different
than the ingot material.
Why is that important?
Well, if you're trying to
displace the dominant design,
the wafer, you would do well to
make your wafer the same size
and shape as the
dominant design.
Why is that?
Well, if you want to make a cell
out of it or solar cell device,
you'd want to make
sure that you can
take advantage of the same
manufacturing equipment.
And that's just a
plug-in-and-play,
drop-in replacement.
If you require customization
of the downstream components
on the cell in the
module level, you'll
wind up having to invest more
money in those processes, which
might counteract the
advantage that you get out
of using less silicon.
Yes, Ashley?
AUDIENCE: What's capex?
Is it--
PROFESSOR: Oh, capex.
Capex stands for capital
expenditure, capital equipment
expenditure.
And that relates to the
cost of the equipment that
is typically-- well, in the
business world, typically
one undergoes what's called an
accelerated depreciation where
you amortize the cost of the
equipment over five years
but then assume that it runs
over a longer period, maybe
7, 10 years or so
giving you profit back.
So in layman's terms,
what this means is capex
is the equipment
cost, in other words.
And then you just take
the cost of the equipment
and parse it out.
For each wafer you produce,
you allocate a portion
of equipment cost to that.
So let's take a little
walk through history
and go back to some
of the earliest
methods of ribbon growth.
So one of the earliest
forms of ribbon growth
was the so-called edge
supported ribbon, also known
as string ribbon.
And there were developments
of this general technology
in different places.
Ely Sachs, former
professor here at MIT, now
founder and CTO of 1366
Technologies just up
the road in Lexington, developed
the string ribbon material
here at MIT in the
early 1980s, late 1970s.
And the general idea
was to use two filaments
like so that would be
passed through a crucible.
And then the silicon
would flow in
between those two filaments
much like soapy water
flows between the little
circle when you blow bubbles.
So a meniscus would form here
and then eventually solidify
into a solid piece
of silicon, and you'd
have edge-supported ribbon,
otherwise known as string
ribbon because you're
using the strings to define
the edge of the ribbon.
So I have a wafer here, an
example of a wafer here,
a string ribbon sample.
Oh, here it is.
It's hiding from me.
So this is an example of
one of those materials.
Here we go.
And like usual, it's good
to handle these wafers
with some care almost
like a photograph.
So here's an example
of a string ribbon
wafer, one particular wafer
that was laser cut out
of a growing ribbon.
As you can see, this larger
ribbon right here-- these
can grow up to be
a few meters long.
They're rather long.
You can pick them up if you
have gloves on your hands.
And they're quite
flexible at that length.
You could actually
even bend them
with a radius of curvature
of about a couple of meters.
So the reason you wear
gloves, obviously,
is to prevent your fingers
some soiling the wafer.
We talked about sodium
contamination and other forms
of contamination.
Silicon is nontoxic,
so it won't affect you.
It's really you
affecting the wafer,
much like putting
fingerprints all over
a nice, clean photograph.
So there were
similar technologies
developed by Ted [INAUDIBLE]
at NREL out in Colorado.
But the general idea
is shown right here.
Now some of the earliest
edge-supported ribbon samples
were developed back in 1970s.
It really took a
while before they
were commercialized in full.
And that was done through
Evergreen Solar, which
was founded in 1994 by Jack
Hanoka, Rich Chlebowski,
and-- oh, goodness--
Mark Farber.
So the three of them a
co-founded Evergreen Solar.
And they developed the
string ribbon growth process
shown right over here.
Eventually two ribbons face
to face, and now four ribbons
side by side.
So this was called the
Gemini because there
were two ribbons face to face.
And then eventually,
the quad process
were four ribbons edge to edge.
And you can see the
conventional ingot
multi-crystalline silicon.
Here, the different
steps forming the ingot,
eventually slicing, and so
forth and the string ribbon
process here being much
simplified in correspondence.
So not only was the
process simpler,
but you'd use about
half as much silicon.
And here's Rick Wallace,
the inventor and developer
of the Gemini process,
up there showing
one of these longer meter-length
ribbons with some flexibility.
So the company had
a joint venture
with REC and Q-Cells,
Norwegian and German companies
respectively, to form
a factory in Germany.
REC would supply the
silicon feedstock,
Evergreen the growth
technology here,
and Q-Cell some of the
cell fabrication expertise.
And very recently,
Evergreen Solar
encountered some
financial difficulties--
we'll get into that during the
third section of the course
when we talk about
cross-cutting themes-- and is
in the process of
filing for bankruptcy.
So this process-- so Sovello is
continuing as its own company,
but the Evergreen plant here in
Massachusetts in Marlborough,
about an hour west of here,
has effectively shut down.
So that was the trajectory
of this particular technology
through commercialization
and ultimately not making it.
If you would like,
my personal opinion
about why Evergreen
never quite took off,
yes, there are some
technical factors,
but as well it failed to
grow fast enough to keep up
with the rest of the
industry and scale
with the rest of the industry.
And part of that
can be traced back
to the mid 2000s when
silicon was scarce,
the inability to source
the feedstock material.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
Can you back one slide?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
It takes a while.
It's a big file.
OK.
AUDIENCE: How do you seal the
space between the filaments
and the bottom of the crucible?
PROFESSOR: Right there, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Since this is your
graphite crucible right here
and these are your
filaments popping up
through the graphite, the beauty
is you don't have to seal that.
The surface tension of silicon
is greater than that of water.
So if you've ever filled up
water to the top of a glass
and seen that
meniscus that forms,
the silicon meniscus would
be even higher than that.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's cool.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's pretty nifty.
AUDIENCE: So I'm imagining
just like molten metal.
You don't want that
spilling out the bottom.
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: That's really cool.
OK.
Cool.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are the
ribbons a single crystal?
Or are there grain
boundaries in them?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So let me show you the
actual ribbon right here,
and you can inspect
it first hand.
These do indeed have
grain boundaries.
So what I'll do is I'll place
the ribbon inside of here
for ease of carrying around.
If you'd like to take
it out, feel free.
They're more where
this came from.
So in case there was a little
accident along the way,
don't feel too bad.
The growth of an ingot
is about one to two days,
but you get thousands
of wafers out.
The growth of a wafer itself--
if the growth rate was around,
say, let's pick a number
somewhere between 2
and 5 centimeters
per minute, then
it would take--
let's see, with this,
you have a 15
centimeter wafer-- it
would take somewhere on
the order of four minutes
to grow wafer.
And you'd have a faster
growth of single wafers
from the ribbon process, of
course, lower throughput.
The silicon utilization of
the wafer growth process
was a lot higher than
that of the ingot growth.
Some smart people
realized along the way
that you could grow
these ribbons vertically,
but you encountered
the following problem.
During the growth
of-- here you go.
During the growth of
a vertical ribbons,
if this was the ribbon
growing vertically--
it should be straight.
Apologies.
There we go.
Let's make sure we're
good engineers here.
And so this is meant to
represent a growing ribbon.
This is the liquid, and this is
the solid silicon right here.
The growth velocity would be
in this direction right here.
So you're growing the ribbon out
of the melt. This is your melt.
This is the ribbon
that's growing up.
You're looking at the
cross section right here,
so looking at the
ribbon edge on.
So you're pulling it
in this direction,
so the growth velocity is here.
And the direction of
latent heat of fusion
extraction-- so you have liquid
silicon solidifying here.
During the solidification
process, there's heat released.
And that heat has
to be conducted up
the solid and then radiated
outward from the fin,
from this thin ribbon.
So the direction
of heat extraction
is also parallel to the
direction of growth.
What that means is
the growth velocity
will be limited by the speed
at which you can extract heat
up the ribbon and
then radiated outward.
So there are many
ideas tossed around
about potentially
growing in media
that are able to extract
heat [INAUDIBLE] transport.
You can use your imagination.
But ultimately, growth
continues in air,
and you're limited to, at
most, around 5 centimeters
per minute growth velocity
because of the extraction
of latent heat.
If you try to grow
faster than that,
you'll eventually just pull
the solid off of the liquid.
It'll dissociate much like
pulling an ice cube off
of a top of a glass of water.
Surface tension won't be able
to hold the two together.
So you have here a conundrum.
How do you grow faster?
If you want to
increase the throughput
and instead of spending
minutes to grow wafer,
you'd like to grow a wafer per
second, how do you do that?
Well, one group of folks thought
about this a bit and said,
well, what if we do this?
If we take our growth velocity
and in some way, shape, or form
now our growth
velocity is going to be
perpendicular to the
direction of heat extraction,
what would that
geometry look like?
And they came up
with something that
looked a bit like
this right here,
a horizontal growth mechanism.
So you see the [INAUDIBLE]
interface is now at an angle.
It's almost vertical at
this point, a slight angle.
And the pull velocity is
almost perpendicular to it.
So now, you're able,
in theory at least,
to grow much, much faster.
This was a schematic
of the ribbon
growth on silicon process.
There's also another
company called AstroPower
that developed silicon film.
It was later purchased
by General Electric.
So these technologies were
developed with the intent
of pulling very, very fast.
And indeed, you can
literally extrude the silicon
at around 49 meters per second.
But the problem about
this is that you wind up
with very small grains and very
poor crystalline quality when
you try to grow at the speeds.
And so it winds up being a
metallurgical problem of how
do you ensure the proper
grain size when you're growing
using these technologies?
So there is some
work in that regard,
but never really took off
in commercial production.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So does
pulling at a lower
speed with the horizontal
ribbon increase
your quality by increasing
your grain size?
Or is it not really--
PROFESSOR: If you're able
to control the nucleation
and growth process at the
very beginning, theoretically,
that could be possible.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: You had mentioned form
factor for these wafers before.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is there like
a standard form factor
for solar cell manufacturing?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So the standard form factor
today is akin to this one right
here.
It's about a 15.6
by 15.6 centimeter
squared lateral dimension
form factor for the wafer.
And I can pass this
one around as well.
This right here is what's
called a "pseudo-square."
You can see the edges
are kind of rounded off.
And that's because it came
from a CZ wafer like this one.
It was just chopped out of it.
Let me see if these
two are coincidence.
It would be a-- oh, yeah.
Look at that.
So you can see where the
solar cell actually came from.
So that's the standard
diameter of a, say,
linear dimension, usually
rectilinear shape, a square.
And the multi-crystalline
silicon ingot material
are typically of
this size as well.
And you can already see
that these wafers that I
have up here are a bit small.
These were the previous
generation size.
I believe these are 12.5
by 12.5 centimeter squared.
Most laboratory devices
that you and your colleagues
will manufacture are
on the order of 1
by 1 centimeter or
smaller because-- well,
because of a variety of factors.
One is the transparent
conducting oxide
as we saw in our
homework problem.
We're limited in how big we can
make the device by the sheet
resistance of that
transparent conducting oxide.
Another problem that
we typically run into
is just that we're
not able to deposit
uniformly over a large area.
We don't have a deposition
equipment for it in our labs.
We're there trying to
optimize a new material.
We don't necessarily worry about
making module-sized devices out
of it.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
reason why the form
factor is different than that
used for device manufacturing?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Like [INAUDIBLE]
uses circular wafers.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if we were to imagine a
bunch of circular wafers inside
of this module over here, you
can imagine the circular wafers
side by side.
That was how they were
done at once upon a time.
Obviously you
didn't have 8-inch.
It was much smaller.
Or a 6- or 8-inch.
This would be a 6-inch wafer.
But the wafers were
a little smaller,
but you still have
circular wafers and a lot
of dead space in between.
So as you can see, because
of the rounded edges,
the packing density is very low.
The equivalent would
be, say, oranges
at a market where they're
all stacked on top of another
and you have all this
dead space in between.
And so the idea was to optimize
between the cost of the silicon
and the cost of the encapsulant
materials by shaving away
a little bit of the
silicon and losing that--
and perhaps recycling
it, to be honest--
and the encapsulant
materials, where
you have this dead space
in between the wafers,
a small amount of
it, where you have
glass and encapsulant but
no active device underneath.
Another interesting
development, as you can see just
from the device point
of view-- so this
would be an Evergreen string
ribbon wafer right here, as you
can see.
And this right here,
a larger area device.
Does anybody notice a
difference besides the shape?
In particular, I lead
you to the busbars.
How many of those
thick, vertical lines
appear down the wafer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This has two,
and this has three, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So the
busbars-- the optimization
of these busbars-- this one
has three-- that's really
to minimize series resistance.
Because now that I
have a larger wafer,
you have so much current flowing
through it, being generated,
that the series resistance
through those very thin metal
wires would end up resulting
in large power losses,
essentially heat
instead of electricity.
And so they added
the third busbar,
even though it increased the
shading, to reduce the series
resistance losses.
So you can see these
optimization problems are
used quite frequently in solar.
Let me go back one step.
There was an
interesting question
about could we grow
single crystals using
the vertical ribbon growth.
This is a technology.
And I don't know if
there are actually
any of these, many of these
samples left in the world.
They're quite rare.
So I do ask if you
want to come up
here, take some care with it.
This is a dendritic web sample.
So this technology went out
of commercial manufacturing,
I believe, in 2005.
Must have been.
Or 2004.
It was developed
by Westinghouse,
which is used to be one of the
powerhouses in solar located
in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
They had a very
active solar activity.
It was a kind of a crucible
out of which many solar experts
then went into diaspora
around the United States
and set up their own
activities elsewhere.
And one of the technologies
that they developed
was a single crystalline ribbon
technology like this right
here.
And if you look very closely,
it really is a single crystal.
The growth methods
to make this, though,
was extremely intricate.
It involved, among other things,
control of the temperature,
of the liquid silicon to within
1/100 of a degree Celsius
at melting temperature, which is
an extreme feat of engineering.
The uptime of these
pieces of equipment,
meaning the growth
time, was around 50%.
And the other 50% of
the time, the operators
were trying to make it work.
So it grew very,
very thin material.
It wasn't able to scale
to the form factors
that we see nowadays.
The throughput was quite low.
The cost was high.
And so it didn't quite make
it, but from an engineering
point of view, it was a
marvel in terms of what
they were able to accomplish.
So history of crystalline
silicon development
is riddled with these
technologies that didn't quite
make it with these
materials that
were extremely inventive,
extremely ingenuitive.
But at the end of the day,
the dollars per watt peak
just couldn't continue to
justify their existence.
And there were a number of
factors that could contribute
to making that happen.
So in terms of wafer
fabrication in general--
this includes both the
wafers out of ingot materials
but also ribbons--
where do I personally
see this field going?
These are some notes.
So in terms of cost,
the cost per watt peak
can be reduced by using
cheaper starting materials.
That means instead of using this
expensive Siemens poly, perhaps
an upgraded metallurgical
silicon process.
Growing or sawing
thinner wafers.
Growing, for example,
on a ribbon technique.
Sawing, maybe making the saws
themselves thinner but more
robust so that they
don't snap as they're
pulling through the material
at about 5 meters per second
in that slurry with the silicon
carbide or diamond grit.
Very challenging
engineering as well.
This second bullet
point right there
can be encapsulated in a larger
team called improved silicon
materials utilization.
In other words, the
grams of silicon
that you use to produce a
watt peak of a solar cell.
So improving that
number right there.
Increasing furnace
throughput-- that means
increasing ingot size,
growth, speed, and so forth.
There are many people
right now trying
to grow these
ingot right here up
to a ton, one metric
ton, so 1,000 kilograms.
That would mean for
the full-sized wafers,
you would have something on
the order of 6 by 6 bricks.
It's pretty large, a
pretty large ingot.
Maybe even 7 by 7.
And improving the
material quality
so that you can
improve efficiency,
efficiency being a huge leverage
over the entire cost structure.
Because if your solar cell is
able to produce more power,
that means that you use less
encapsulant, and less material,
and so forth per unit power
produced, and even less
labor to install it and
less racking and framing
materials downstream.
The scaling issues, so
polysilicon production
is currently-- well,
this is higher now.
It's about 100,000
metric tons per year.
And about half of that--
well, about a quarter of that,
now, maybe a third is for
the semiconductor industry,
about 3/4 for the PV industry.
The slurry and the
silicon carbide grit
needed for wire sawing
is, at some point,
going to become an issue.
These are huge
volumes of waste that
need to be transported
through the factories.
And of course, the silicon loss
due to wire sawing and ingot
casting, resulting in
only 50% of the silicon
here in this ingot being
used in the actual wafers
to make solar cells.
The technology
enablers-- using lower--
let's put it this--
lower cost feedstocks.
You can't compromise
on quality ultimately,
so this is a little bit of
a false choice right here.
Using lower cost
feedstocks produced
by the upgraded metallurgical
route, for example.
Producing and
handling thinner wafer
and growing faster, larger,
higher quality ingots.
And there's a lot
of innovation to be
had in this space right here.
I believe the numbers
in the last quarter,
start-up companies raised
on the order of $250 million
from venture capital.
And that wasn't including
a new $50 million
deal that was just announced
of a company attempting
to produce upgraded
metallurgic grade
silicon through liquid
routes, purification.
This was just announced
this past week,
if you go to Greentech Media.
So there's still a lot of
active innovation in this area
despite the current
market conditions.
And those of you who are
looking for jobs right now,
if you're clever, you'll
find them here in this space.
Any questions so
far about wafers?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does laser
cutting cause as much dust?
PROFESSOR: Does laser
So let's walk through that.
If we're thinking about
the ribbon growing from,
say-- from this
ribbon right here,
I'm going to extract this wafer.
So I need to make an
incision horizontally
right around this
point right here.
If you look at the total
height, the wafer's
around 15 centimeters long.
And the laser cut
itself is something
on the order of
maybe, oh-- I'm going
to guess-- a few tens
of microns, maybe
100 microns in that order.
And so that the amount of
kerf loss in that regard
would be 100 microns over 15
centimeters, so a relatively
insignificant fraction.
If you're trying to chop up
this using a laser, yes, then
you would have
significant losses.
But since you're growing
that ribbon straight out
of the melt, the
laser cuts themselves
are a very small fraction
of the total silicon.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Can the sawdust be
collected and remelted then?
PROFESSOR: Wonderful question.
Can the sawdust be collected
and remelted again?
There was a lot of work done
to try to figure that out.
At that point, the
sawdust is mixed
with this glycol-based slurry,
and with the silicon carbide
grit, and with fragments of iron
coming from the stainless steel
wire, and nickel and
chromium and other impurities
inside of the wire.
And so a lot of the
work was focused
on separation of those different
constituents, shall we say.
And when the silicon prices were
very high, maybe in 2007, 2008,
when the spot prices
were $500 a kilogram,
there was a large
incentive to use
every single drop of silicon
you had including separation.
But in recent years,
the incentive to do that
has really dropped.
And the one company I knew
that had a very active slurry
recycling program let it go.
So there may be companies out
there that are looking into it,
but I'm not aware
of their activities.
OK.
Let's hop forward into
cells and devices.
So now we've talked
about the market shares
of different technologies,
feedstock refining, wafer
fabrication, how we make these
wonderful different pieces
of silicon.
Now we're going to talk
about going from a wafer
into a solar cell device.
So just to situate
ourselves, raw material,
silicon feedstock, the module
in the system over here.
In the middle, we have
the wafer to the cell.
And this is the portion
of discussion forthwith.
Cell processing.
Let's have a look at this.
Again, it's a very
different world
now in a cell fab line then
it was in the crystallisation
environment.
So in wafer fab, which
means wafer fabrication
and the section of
the company dedicated
to producing wafers and ingots,
it was a little bit more dirty.
You had forklifts moving
these big crucibles around
with chunks of silicon
in it, operators
coming by with garden hoses
and washing down furnaces
after they're finished.
Here in the cell
fab line, it looks
almost more like a clean room.
Almost, I say,
because these folks
aren't in full bunny suits.
They're usually just with
jackets with booties.
Sometimes you see
them with hair nets
as well to protect from hair
and other particulate matter
from getting inside
of the tools.
But by and large, the
wafers are brought in.
And either in a series
of inline processes--
this is a wafer,
wafer, wafer, wafer.
So there are four
wafers across moving
through what looks
like an etch tank
to do the texturization
on the wafers.
Whereas in wafer fab,
it was pretty dirty.
In cell fab, it
looks pretty clean.
You have a combination
of these inline processes
like this one shown here.
We have wafers on conveyor
belts moving through lines.
And batch processes, where
little robots [? pick in ?]
places, line wafers up
inside of crucibles or boats,
and insert them into furnaces
for batch processing.
So this is the crystalline
silicon cell fabrication.
In on one side go
bare wafers like this,
and out the other side come
fully processed solar cell
devices.
So the very first step
after wafer sawing
is the saw damage etch.
After the sawing process,
you have subsurface damage,
something on the order
of 5 to 10 microns
deep beneath the
wafer's surface.
And keep in mind these are
only about 170 microns thick.
So you have subsurface damage
that needs to be removed.
And you can take advantage
of the subsurface damage
by etching it in such a way
that you etch along the damage
and form texturization.
So it's a bit of
a two-in-one here.
You clean the wafer, you
create your texturization,
and you remove
your saw damage so
that when you lift your
wafer, the wafer doesn't
break because there's some
hairline fracture caused
by the silicon carbide grit.
After you have
your wafer-- so you
start with your p-type wafer.
And this represents
the cross section
of the wafer from the
backside of the eventual cell
to the front side of
the eventual cell,
about 170 microns thick.
Wide would be something on
the order of 15.6 centimeters
in a real device.
We're just looking at a
small section of it here.
So as we walk through the
different steps of cell fab,
we'll see them evolve over here.
The first step after
the saw damage etch
is to do what's called an
emitter diffusion, to create
your p-n junction.
Straight out of the
box, the p-n junction
is created after
the saw damage etch.
And typically, what we do is
deposit a lower resistance
or more highly doped-- that's
why we have the 2 pluses here,
that means very highly
doped-- emitter right
underneath where the eventual
contact metalization will go.
That's to reduce the
contact resistance.
That's to create the
tunneling junction
between the semiconductor
and the metal.
OK.
So we have the high
resistance emitter over here.
This is representative
of a shallow emitter.
You remember in
your quiz two you
have this decision whether
to take a shallow or deep.
This architecture, which
is used in industry,
actually combines the
best of both worlds.
It has a shallow emitter over
most of the solar cell device
to improve the blue response,
minimize Auger recombination.
But it also has a deeper emitter
right underneath the contact
metalization to prevent
shunting and to reduce
contact resistance.
AUDIENCE: I assume we have
to choose one or the other.
PROFESSOR: You have to choose
one or the other unfortunately.
To create this-- it's really to
create the combination, what's
called a selective emitter.
It's an emitter because
it's the charge separation
portion of the device.
But it's also
selective in the sense
that you selectively place
these low resistance portions
across in a geometric fashion
underneath your eventual
contact metalization.
You have at the end
of this diffusion
process what's called a
phosphorus silicate glass etch,
PSG, Phosphorus
Silicate Glass etch.
After defusing in the phosphorus
in the gaseous form, what
you'll do-- or
actually, you'll watch
it being done, since it's
happening inside of a furnace.
This phosphorus-based gas will
deposit a thin glassy layer
on the surface of
the sample, which
then needs to be etched
off or removed before you
can do further processing.
So that's what the phosphorus
silicate glass etch is about.
Then there's a nitride or a
silicon nitride anti-reflection
coating that's placed
on the front surface.
And as we calculated
in lecture number two,
this silicon nitride
coating is only how thick?
About?
AUDIENCE: 70 nanometers.
PROFESSOR: 70 nanometers, right?
It's really, really thin.
But yet, that's enough to create
that quarter wave interference
effect that leads to a very
blue looking solar cell device.
So the reason they
looked blue is
because of that
anti-reflection coating.
We are going to omit the ARC
coating in our design for quiz
number two.
It requires silane gas,
which we don't have access
to down here in the laboratory.
We'd have to go to either
[? NTL ?] or Harvard CNS
to get that deposited.
So because we want this to
be a hands-on experience,
we don't to take the
wafers out of your hands,
do some magic off to the
side, and bring them back
and say, oh, here you go.
Because your level of
ownership in the process
just plummets in order of
magnitude in the process.
We want you to be able to
see it every step of the way.
So we omit the anti-reflection
coating in our quiz number two.
But in commercial
production, that's done.
And people pay a lot of
attention to that step.
And finally, the metalization
is deposited on the sample
and fired.
Now, the metalization,
how is it deposited?
We'll see in a few slides
what the screen printing
process looks like.
And then, we'll actually
do it ourselves.
You'll press the
button on the tool
and deposit your
metal on yourself.
But the metalization
is typically
deposited onto the devices on
the front side and on the back.
The front side, you have to line
up-- in commercial production--
line up with the low resistance
portion of the emitter
so that you are able to
extract the full benefit
from the selective
emitter design
and not shunt your
device elsewhere.
And on the back contact,
this is typically aluminum.
The aluminum, some
of the aluminum
will indiffuse into the silicon
and create a p-plus region
in the back side here, which
is a minority carrier blockade
layer.
It pushes the electrons
away from the back junction
and toward the emitter.
And so it prevents back
surface recombination.
So you see every
single little step
of the solar cell fabrication.
A lot of smart people spend
a lot of time thinking about,
gee, how do I optimize two
or three things at once?
Question up there?
AUDIENCE: So both the front
side and backside metalization
is [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No the front side
metalization in this case--
thank you for that
clarification-- the front side
metalization in
this case would be
silver or silver-based paste.
And in most
commercial production,
this silver-based paste
includes metal oxides.
It could be glassy frit.
It could be lead oxide.
It could be some
combination of elements.
That is able to etch through the
silicon nitride anti-reflective
coating.
This is only 70
nanometers thick,
but silicon nitride is
a very strong material.
It's a ceramic material.
So you have to be able to etch
through the silicon nitride
and make electrical contact
with the silicon underneath.
And some of the earliest screen
printed metalization cells that
got in the range of 15%
or 16% efficiency only
made electrical contact
about 10% of the silicon.
But it was enough to have these
percolation paths for current
to flow up into
the metalization.
It's a miracle that
it works at all.
But it's a very effective,
cheap manufacturing process
that, nevertheless,
is still being
used in commercial
production today, even
among some of the highest
efficiency cell architectures.
And so for each of these
different processing steps,
somebody had to sit
there and think deeply
about optimization of
different functions.
The [? aluminium ?] on
the backside, somebody
had to think about,
gee, how do I
prevent the wafer from
bowing, bowing too much,
due to coefficient
of thermal expansion
mismatch between the
aluminium and the silicon?
Somebody had to think about, how
do I create the right eutectic
with the silicon-- the
aluminum silicon eutectic
is around 577
degrees Celsius-- so
that you create a good ohmic
contact on the backside?
How do I diffuse in a certain
amount of the aluminum
to create this back surface
field to prevent back
surface recombination?
How do I get the right
back surface reflectance
of the light coming
off of here so
that I have multiple optical
bounces through my device
and so forth?
So a lot of optimization goes
into making a solar cell device
to get the Liebig's
law of the minimum,
to get each plank Liebig's
law as high as you possibly
can so you can achieve a
high device performance.
So hopefully, this
walk through now,
you can have an appreciation
for the difficulty
that some of your colleagues
face at solar cell fabrication
plants.
Finally, as last
steps-- I mean, this
is a real miniature
cross section
in the lateral
dimension right here.
We only have two contact
metalization fingers.
If you look at this solar
cell device right here,
we have several dozen, right?
If I were to make a vertical
cross section through it,
you'd see several
dozen contact fingers.
But this is just meant
to be a caricature.
So on the edge here,
we have edge isolation.
And what this is doing is
preventing shunting pathways
from going around to the back.
So it's preventing
the emitter from being
able to make electrical contact
to the backside of the device.
And this is typically
done by inserting
a trench, a laser-based
trench, just-- gosh,
it must be on the order of half
a millimeter from the edge.
I'm going to pass this around,
this solar cell device right
here.
And if you look
very, very carefully,
it's literally a few hundred
microns from the edge at most.
You may be able to see the
edge isolation, the trench that
is formed by the laser.
But it's very difficult to see.
So I'll pass this finished
device around as well.
And feel free to
pick it up and look
at the backside
and the front side.
On the back, you'll
see some silver paths
in the middle of
all that aluminum.
And if anybody has ever
tried to solder to aluminum,
you know exactly why those
silver pads are there.
It's so you can solder
to them and make contact
to the back of one
device and contact it
to the front of the next.
And you'll notice
that they're aligned,
so the back pads are
aligned with the front.
So I'll pass this
around right here.
Yes, Ashley?
AUDIENCE: I assume
that in order to go
in terms of where you want
to put the edge isolation,
do you want it as
far out as possible
so you're not losing
that edge part.
But you also need to
make sure you're actually
making a full [INAUDIBLE].
There's some optimization--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
If your laser edge isolation
machine isn't well-calibrated,
you're losing area, active
area, of your solar cell,
hence your current output
is going to be lower.
Because you know your solar cell
has a certain current density,
a certain, say, milliamps
per square centimeter.
But then if your area, if
you're square centimeter
is smaller, because
you're cutting too far
away from the edge, you're
throwing away good material.
This isn't the trench
all the way through.
It's just electrical isolation.
So essentially, this material
over here still exists.
It's still hanging
on to the device,
but it's electrically isolated.
This trench here is only about
a couple of microns deep.
And you're losing area.
This area over here
is not contributing
to the photocurrent
of your device.
Any electron making it up
into the emitter over here
will just stay there and
recombine eventually.
It won't be able to be
pulled out of the device.
A funny, but true story--
there was a company
once that I worked with
to solve a problem.
And they were getting
lower efficiencies
in their new process.
And they couldn't figure
out for the life of them
why they were getting
lower efficiencies.
They checked everything,
everything, everything,
everything.
And it turned out that they
were cutting their wafers
to a slightly larger size
than they were before.
Actually, it was a
slightly smaller size,
because it was a
lower efficiency.
And their tester had embedded in
it a fixed number for the area.
It wasn't measuring the area
of each wafer independently.
It just had a fixed number
for the area of the cell.
And so it was dividing
the total current output
by a bigger area than
what was actually there.
And so it was "measuring"
a lower efficiency
than what actually the
cell was outputting.
So again, these
geometric parameters
can come up and
bite you if you're
so fixated on the electrical
performance parameters.
Testing and sorting.
So after you create
your device, you
have this beautiful solar cell.
And just from simple electrical
engineering and maybe
as an extreme example if you're
stringing Christmas lights
together, you know that
if you have one bad apple,
it can drag down the performance
of the entire string,
right, if you're
connecting these in series.
And so it makes sense to
test each of the cells
individually and make sure
that you sort them together
with their like cousins.
So if you have high
performance cells,
you bin them all together.
And you make models of the
high performance cells.
These will be high
performance modules.
The bad apples you put
together with the bad apples
and so forth.
And that way you can extract
the maximum value out
of the product you've created.
You take your good
cells, you put them
into a higher efficiency module.
It looks exactly the same,
but its producing more power,
so you can sell that module at
a higher price than you would,
say, a lower power
output module.
OK.
So that's what the test
and sort is all about.
Turnkey solar cell
fabrication lines,
very common since the mid 2000s.
There are companies--
Centrotherm, gosh, [INAUDIBLE],
Roth & Rau, others that were
producing either turnkey
equipment or even turnkey lines
for the entire fabrication
line.
Even a local company,
Spire, just up
the road here in Massachusetts.
These typically consisted
of wafer inspection systems
on the input side.
You don't want to invest
any money in a wafer that's
ultimately going
to break, so you
want to be able to inspect your
wafers coming in to make sure
that they're high enough
quality to be worthy
of your cell investment.
Next, you have wet processing
to do the texturization.
That's shown right there.
Saw damage texturization.
And these are
typically inline tools
with little ceramic rollers,
some pretty nasty acids
being use.
Silicon is like a rock.
And if you want
to etch the rock,
you need to have some pretty
strong solutions, some very
high or very low pH, very basic
or very acidic respectively.
And most of the time, in
multi-crystalline silicon,
we use an acidic solution.
It textures the
wafer independent
of grain orientation.
For the single
crystal materials,
we use a basic solution that
is isotropic or anisotropic
in nature.
It creates nice little pyramids.
So here, you see the wafers
being drawn over an etch bath.
And very small
quantities of liquid
are used per wafer
in this arrangement.
You just coat the wafer's
surface, and that's about it.
If you were to do
it in a batch mode,
you need a big bath
like a bathtub.
And you dunk your
wafers inside of it.
So that would be the bathtub.
This would be the
shower equivalent.
So more water efficient.
In this case, acid efficient.
And then the cells come
out on the other side
and go into the emitter
diffusion process.
And these are a
series of furnaces.
We'll see one such furnace
over the course of quiz two
when we make our solar cells.
So this is the phosphorus
diffusion furnace right here.
The wafers are typically loaded
into boats and then inserted
into furnace where phosphorus
containing gas, POCL3,
also called "pah-cul," is
flown into the chamber.
The chlorine components
and the oxygen
dissociate from the
phosphorus, which
is then driven into the wafer.
The oxygen reacts
with the silicon,
creates that phosphorus
silicate glass on the surface.
And the phosphorus is driven
into the solar cell creating
the p-n junction,
creating your device.
And here's an example of
Czochralski wafers being loaded
into the phosphorus diffusion
furnace and then out again,
just showing the
degree of automation
of some of these furnaces.
This showing a
stack not dissimilar
from the one in the
laboratory downstairs
in building 35 where we'll be
doing our phosphorus diffusion.
So the next-- after we have our
p-n junction-- the next step
would be to create the
anti-reflection coating.
And this is done by a process
called Plasma Enhanced Chemical
Vapor Deposition,
or PECVD for short.
And in the PECVD process, you
flow in silane gas and ammonia.
Silane is silicon with a bunch
of hydrogens, four of them.
And ammonia is nitrogen
with a bunch of hydrogens.
And the nitrogen and the silicon
react on the wafer's surface
and create the silicon
nitride coating.
The hydrogens, 90% of
it, evaporates off.
But about 10% of
it hangs around.
Between 1% and 10% go into the
wafer or stay at the interface
there and eventually are driven
into the wafer passivating
bulk defects.
So again, a multitude
of different things
going on at the same time.
Eventually, the
visible effect is
that you've created your
anti-reflection coating.
The wafers go in looking shiny
and come out looking blue.
But what's happening
underneath the surface
is that some of the hydrogen
is going into the wafer.
Hydrogen, the first element on
the periodic table, very tiny.
And in the PECVD process,
where you have a plasma,
you have hydrogen
ions, which basically
means you have a proton
without its electron.
And that proton is very fast,
moving through the lattice.
There's lots of space for it
to move through the silicon
lattice.
And it's also very
reactive because it
doesn't have that electron.
So whenever it finds a
defect or a dangling bond,
it'll usually lodge itself
there, and attach itself,
and passivate that defect.
And that's what
hydrogen passivation
is all about during
the silicon nitride
anti-reflective
coating deposition.
These are examples of
inline processes for doing
an anti-reflection coating.
I believe there are a
few different variants
of this inline
process, one of which
is a sputtering
mechanism to deposit
this anti-reflective coating.
Of course, then during
sputtering process,
you have to worry, as
well, about hydrogen.
Do you have the benefit
of hydrogen passivation?
Perhaps not as much, so
additional engineering
is needed.
But the inline process
could be potentially faster
and higher throughput than the
batch process using the PECVD.
So again, manufacturing
trade-offs.
Next, we have the printing
line and screen printing.
So this looks very similar to
screen printing for a t-shirt.
Here is a t-shirt being
loaded into a screen printer.
And here's a solar cell being
loaded into screen printer.
This is a close up of
the screen, of what
the screen actually looks like.
Here, the screen,
which is comprised
of this mesh of metal--
here the screen is bare.
And so the metal
that's deposited on top
can go through those
holes in the screen
and onto the wafer
underneath it.
And here, there's a coating, a
polymer coating of the screen,
which prevents the
metal from going
through the screen
at those places.
So it shades the solar cell
underneath and prevents metals
from being deposited there.
And you have
fingers and busbars.
And those are eventually
the thin little fingers
that you see right
here going sideways
and the vertical
busbars that you see
going vertically right here.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So when you do these [INAUDIBLE]
emitter [INAUDIBLE] where you
have some areas of high
resistance emitters and others
of low resistance--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you use
a screen to shield it.
Or do you [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Great question.
So some of the earliest designs
for the selective emitter--if
we go back all the
way up to here.
Yeah.
To the selective
emitter portion.
So the earliest designs
used photoresist process.
But I would say nowadays,
there are a few technology
options that are much
faster, one of which
involves a creation of porous
silicon on certain regions
of the wafer that you want
to etch back and create
the shallow emitter leaving
the deeper region intact.
And that, you could
use a form of shading.
You could use a wax even for it.
There are a variety
of technology options
for achieving that goal.
But in a sense, many of
the selective emitter
designs involve a deep
diffusion first and then
a partial etch back.
For example, creation
of porous silicon
and etching that material away.
Ashley, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
So what does "turnkey" refer to?
PROFESSOR: Turnkey.
Excellent question.
So turnkey manufacturing
line-- what it refers to
is that I'm the vendor
of the equipment.
In one case, I
say, here, Ashley.
Here's a piece of equipment.
It's going to cost
you $1 million.
And good luck getting
it set up and running.
I'm out of here.
I'll see you.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: A smarter
company might come along
and say, I'm going to
guarantee an output
from my piece of equipment.
I'm going to
guarantee that you'll
be able to make 16.7% solar
cells, 16.7% efficiency.
I will send my engineers
to your factory,
and they will help you get the
equipment set up and running.
And once it's
running up to spec,
then they'll come back home,
and you'll be on your own.
And you'll be able to
optimize it further.
And so you walk in knowing
that you have this guarantee
of a performance.
Then you can go to
your financing agency.
You can go to Joe
and say, hey, Joe,
give me money for
my new factory.
I have a guarantee that
I'm going to hit 16.7%
and have a pathway
to get to 17.2.
My CTO right here thinks--
she's a really small person,
and she has a pathway to get
to another 0.5% out of it.
And so you can go
to your financier
and get money more
easily than, say,
in the first
scenario where you're
given a piece of equipment
and then the person high tails
it out of there.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So turnkey
refers to the idea
that you turn the line on.
You essentially turn
the key, and you're
getting high performance out.
In reality, it takes a month or
two to ramp up to that point.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: To get high yields
and to get high performance.
But you have the
support of the company
there on the ground
helping you achieve that.
And the turnkey
lines were actually
one of the real reasons why
technology flowed around
the planet so quickly.
Because up until
about the mid 2000s,
high efficiency cell was
limited to a few laboratories
and a few companies in the know.
But once turnkey
equipment manufacturers
got into to the
mix, they started
creating these turnkey
lines and selling
the equipment around the
world and the expertise of how
to make high efficiency
devices, both the architecture
and the processing know-how.
And this is how, within
in the last 5 to 10 years,
you've seen such an
explosion of companies
around the globe in all sorts
of places that traditionally
haven't been experts in solar
cell manufacturing suddenly
knowing how to
manufacture solar cells.
It flows.
The know-how flows through
the equipment vendors.
So finally, testing and sorting.
This is the last stage of
the solar cell manufacturing
process.
Here, we see a little
pick-and-place.
That means a little robot that
picks up wafers and deposits
them.
The simplest incarnation
is just suction cup.
The more fancy ones involve
Bernoulli lifters, essentially
pressure differentials
pulling wafers up.
So you have wafers being
loaded onto a conveyor belt,
coming off of one conveyor
belt onto another one.
And they're moving forward.
And what you see right
here in very low resolution
are two probes coming down.
This, evidently, is a two
busbar cell, not a three busbar
cell like this one.
The probes come down and make
contact with the busbars.
And the probes have
multiple contact points,
so the series resistance
along the busbars
is not affecting
your measurement.
Cell efficiency measurement
is always tricky
because depending where
you put your probes,
your measurements are going to
change because of the series
resistance.
So these probes
right here are long,
and they contain
multiple contact points.
And they're essentially
touching the busbars.
And light flashes onto the
device simulating the sun, so
simulating AM 1.5 conditions.
And an IV curve is
measured, is swept.
I can't really tell from the
photograph or from the movie
right here whether the IV curve
is being swept at illumination,
meaning you're sweeping your
voltage when the cell is
illuminated, or whether
the illumination intensity
itself is used to
vary the forward bias
condition of the cell.
They could be doing
it in one of two ways.
But most likely,
what they're doing is
they're flashing the lights,
measuring the IV characteristic
of the device, and
then sorting the cell
based on that performance.
It goes into a computer.
Efficiency is calculated, just
like you did on your homework.
And just like that,
it's calculated.
And then, as the cell
moves down the line,
the robot knows, oh, that's
the cell that got 16.6.
We put it over here.
Oh, that next cell got 16.8.
We put it over there.
Some additional companies sort
their cells based on color
because they want to have
the aesthetic appearance
of homogeneity
within the module.
They want every cell to be
of uniform aesthetic value
inside of a module so that you
have a nice, uniform color.
AUDIENCE: Is that
considered [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Whether or not
this module right here
is considered uniform or
different would depend on you,
Jessica.
You're the customer,
and you decide
whether this is good enough
for you or whether it's not.
AUDIENCE: It's not.
PROFESSOR: It's not?
All right.
Well, then we have
to work harder.
So the customer requirements
really drive the industry.
So some customers
are more discerning.
Obviously, if this is going
to large field installation,
we have big barbed
wire around it.
Who cares as long as
the module's producing
high performance?
But if it's sitting on
the facade of the train
station in downtown
Freiburg, Germany,
where every single
person riding the train,
entering the station,
sees the modules lining
the side of Deutsche
Bahn's headquarters,
you want to make sure
that those look nice.
So there are differences
depending on where they go
and where they're installed.
High efficiency
cell architectures.
So there are a plethora
of different architectures
out there.
There are some that, for
example, put all their contacts
on the backside, so
there's no shading.
And these are interdigitated
positive, negative, positive,
negative, positive,
negative contacts here.
So this is called an
interdigitated back contact
structure.
It's used by the company
called Sun Power.
And so there's no metalization
loss on the front side.
All your contacts
are on the back.
Because lateral
carrier diffusion
is involved, meaning
the carriers have
to diffuse laterally,
they don't have
to diffuse only
one dimensionally,
you probably can't use
PC1D to model this cell.
You'll have to use a
two-dimensional device
simulation like Sentaurus.
If anybody has any
two-dimensional device
simulation questions, Ashley
right here in the front
is our resident expert, so
you're welcome to ask her.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And then there are also
other device architectures
which we'll get to during
our thin films discussions.
A couple of ancillary
topics, barriers to scale.
This is the size of a 1 gigawatt
peak plant manufacturing
facility for wafers,
cells, and modules.
This is a palm tree right here.
These are roads.
So you get a sense of scale.
This is located in Singapore.
It's a company called REC
that has this factory.
These are 18-wheelers
right here that are
taking the materials out and
selling them to customers.
So you get a sense of the
scale of these facilities.
They're rather big.
And if you say, OK,
this is a gigawatt fab,
but we need to be producing on
the scale of terawatts, which
are three orders of
magnitude larger in area
than this, how big is
that factory going to be?
It's about half of the
state of Rhode Island.
Granted, it'll be
distributed throughout
many different regions, but
it's a big, big factory.
So one of the
interesting questions is,
can we produce the
silicon in a faster
way that involves less area?
Because area generally
relates to capital
equipment costs, not
always, but quite typically.
If you have a larger
area because you
need more equipment in
there, for more equipment,
it's a higher cost.
So can the production costs
be reduced by a higher
throughput growth mechanisms?
So instead of using thin film
or crystalline technologies
that are currently being used
today-- apologies for that.
Instead, if we used, let's say,
a float glass-like process.
So these would be extruded
pieces of silicon on some bed
of--I don't know-- liquid
tin would be for float glass,
an equivalent for silicon.
You could reduce the area by
about two orders of magnitude.
And if you envision instead
these high speed printers that
print out your reports for
your exam or class notes,
they're spitting out 55
pages per minute on 8 and 1/2
by 11 inch squared sheets.
If instead those were 15%
solar cells being printed,
you could envision an area the
size of five football fields
instead.
So this starts opening
the mind that, wow,
our way of manufacturing
these solar cells,
this discrete process
where it's very
segregated-- wafer,
cell, and module.
Wafer manufacturing
almost like a commodity.
Ingot of aluminum.
The cell like a device.
The module-- as we'll see in
a second-- like an automobile,
an assembly process.
If instead we managed to
blend these processes together
and reduce the barriers,
the discrete barriers
between these
different processes
and reinvent the
manufacturing process thereof,
we stand to make this a lot
cheaper, and a lot faster,
and a lot smaller to produce.
We might even have our own
solar cell manufacturing
equipment mounted on our desk.
When we need to print a solar
cell device or power something,
we can produce it right there.
So that's kind of the
vision of the future
where this might
be going and why
bright minds like
yourselves are needed.
We talked about silver.
We know there's a limit
for how much silver
can be used in the front
contact metalization.
We're using about
10% of it right now.
And if you're looking
for environmental impact
of crystalline
silicon technologies,
I've included many
different sites
right here that talk about
the environmental impact
of solar cell manufacturing
since we have mentioned acids.
We have mentioned
gases like silane.
We've mentioned CO2 production
when we produce the wafers.
We'll talk about this
later on in the class,
but in essence, we're looking
at around 1/10 or 1/20 the CO2
intensity of coal.
So it's not a zero-emission
source to produce that module,
but it certainly is a lot less
than, say, our fossil fuel
sources.
This declining US
market share has really
captured the attention
of politicians
lately, the fact that the US
used to comprise 75% of the PV
production market.
This is to produce and
manufacture the modules.
And today, it's on the order 5%.
This is a risen concern
within many in the DOE
and today's DOE and government.
Meanwhile, the market is
growing substantially.
And so an open
question is, what is
the future of US market share?
If all goes well, we should
have a small Greentech Media
article published on this topic
probably within about a week
or so, so keep your eyes open.
And let me briefly jump
into module manufacturing.
Do we have a question?
Oh, we're all set.
OK.
I'm going to hop into
module manufacturing.
It'll be the last five minutes.
Just to show you how you go
from the cell to the module,
it's an assembly process,
very, very straightforward.
We have coming in here sheets
of glass, encapsulate materials.
And we'll be able to see
this up close and personal
and feel the
materials when we go
visit Fraunhofer CSE in
the first week of November.
We have a field
trip going up there.
That'll be a lot of fun.
And the encapsulants
are a lot of fun.
They're polymers.
They're really tough.
You can take the Tedlar
back skin, this white stuff
here in the back of the device,
that white skin right there.
That's called Tedlar.
As the name would suggest,
it comes from DuPont.
It's a polymer.
Really, really tough.
If try to take some in your
hand and try to tear it,
it's nearly impossible, even
for the strongest people here.
So it's impermeable,
very strong material.
The ethyl vinyl
acetate, or EVA, is
a polymer that infuses the
glass in the front side
with the cell.
And with the Tedlar in
the back, it kind of
forms this sticky,
mushy material
when you heat it up
above 150 degrees C.
And it binds everything together
in what's called a laminate.
So let's walk through
that real quick.
To get to the point
of a module, we
need to take our good
apples with our good apples
or our bad apples with our
bad apples, essentially
the like-binned cells, and
start stringing them together.
That means contacting
the front side
with the backside
of adjacent cells.
So the front of one
cell is connected
to the back of the next.
The front of that one
is connected to the back
to the next, and so forth.
And they're connected in
series in a big, long string.
And that's done at this tabbing,
stringing, and layup table.
Typically, this is done by
an automated solder system.
I just put the cells together,
and it wires them for you.
But usually, there's a manual
inspection process afterward
because sometimes the
soldering isn't perfect.
A human being is typically there
fidgeting through, making sure
that everything is primo.
Then we have the
lamination process,
which takes those strings.
They're very fragile
at this point.
They're just solar
cells connected
with some solder-coated
wire, so they're
very fragile at that point.
And these are then laid
up on the top of sheets
of the encapsulant
materials and the glass
and eventually
laminated together
to form that nice package.
So at the lamination stage,
coming out of the lamination,
we'd have the glass on one side,
the Tedlar in the the back,
and the cells in between
encapsulated by the ethyl vinyl
acetate, the EVA.
And we wouldn't have
the frame yet around it.
And so the put that
frame, we would
need essentially a
large machine that
takes those pieces
of extruded aluminum
and pushes them together around
the edges of the laminate,
fixing them on there.
And this is the examples of
the tabbing and stringing
right there.
And let's see, OK.
So the framing
materials right here
are typically done by machines
in places with high labor
costs.
And they're done by human
beings pushing them together
at regions of low labor cost.
And finally, the junction
box is deposited at the end.
And the junction
box, what it does
is it collects the power
outputs from each of the cells
and very conveniently
gives you two leads.
So there could be some power
electronics inside of here
that allows the current
to flow around this module
if this module's under
performing, if it's broken,
or if it's shaded.
There would be a bypass diode
inside of the junction box
that allows the power to
flow around the module
and not get sunk into it.
And it also works to
collect the power outputs
from all the cells and
produces two leads,
which can then be
conveniently plugged
into either adjacent modules,
which would be strung
in series, or into an inverter,
which would then take the DC
power here and convert it into
AC power for your consumption.
And that is how a
solar cell is made.
So I welcome you to spend a
few minutes at the very end
to come up and take a close
look at some of these materials.
Ask some further questions.
And on Thursday,
we'll start diving
into thin film technologies
and talk about how
those are made as well.